>> Sean: WELCOME BACK.
SPECIAL EDITION OF HANNITY.
ALL THROUGHOUT THE RUSSIA
COLLUSION INVESTIGATION THE
MODIA HAS DONE A GREAT
DISSERVICE TO YOU, USING THE
PLATFORM, POWERFUL PLATFORMS TO
ATTACK THE PRESIDENT.
THEY DIDN’T DIG FOR THE TRUTH.
HERE WITH REACTION FORMER WHITE
HOUSE PRESS SECRETARY SEAN
SPICER.
IDENTIFY DON’T KNOW HOW YOU DID
THAT JOB.
I DON’T KNOW HOW SARAH SANDERS
DOES THE JOB.
I WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO DO THAT
JOB.
IT WOULD BE ENTERTAINING FOR
ABOUT A DAY.
AND WOULDN’T END WELL.
BUT SERIOUS NOTE, WHEN YOU HAVE
RUSSIAN COLLUSION, AND HILLARY
PAYING FOR A RUSSIAN DOSSIER, TO
LIE TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE,
DON’TLY UNVERIFIED, USED FOR A
FISA WANT, THE BULK.
INFORMATION UNVERIFIED.
YOU HAVE THE 2009 ISSUE OF PUTIN
OPERATIVES IN THE UNITED STATES
COMMITTING KROIMS TRYING TO GET
WHO THE URANIUM MARKET.
WE IGNORE IT, EVEN THOUGH WE HAD
AN INFORMANT.
HOW IS IT POSSIBLE THAT THE
PRESS ONLY CARES ABOUT TRUMP
RUSSIA AND NOTHING ELSE RUSSIA?
>> WELL, THAT’S BECAUSE THAT’S
WHAT THEY’VE BEEN DOING FOREVER.
IF IT’S AGAINST THE REPUBLICAN
OR CONSERVATIVE THEY GO FULL
BORE, FIND ANY THREAT ON IT AND
TAG OUT F IT’S STARING IN THE
FACE DEMOCRAT OR CLINTON THEY’LL
WALK AWAY IT FROM.
PETER SCHWEITZER, WROTE AN
ENTIRE BOOK ON IT.
.
IT’S ALL LAID OUT THERE, ALL OF
THE MONEY, ALL OF THE ACTIONS,
YOU WILL OF THE PEOPLE INVOLVED.
IT’S LIKE, YOU KNOW, MADE FOR A
GREAT INTERVIEW, ONCE, THEN
EVERYONE MOVED O IF WE’RE GOING
TO TALK ABOUT RUSSIA AND
COLLUSION AND INTERACTION AND
MONEY AND ALL THAT, I THINK THAT
THERE’S A ROAD MAP FOR WHAT THE
CLINTONS DID THAT’S INTERESTING.
JUST BECAUSE SHE LOST THE
ELECTION DOESN’T MEAN THE CRIME
OR POTENTIAL CRIMES SHOULD BE
IGNORED.
>> Sean: WELL, I MEAN, THAT’S
THE WHOLE POINT HERE, REALLY,
DID THEY CARE ABOUT THE TRUTH OR
IS IT, THEY ONLY CARE ABOUT THE
NARRATIVE THAT HURTS THE
PRESIDENT.
I WATCHED THIS DOG AND PONY SHOW
EVERY DAY, YOU DID IT, THEN
SARAH IS DOING IT EVERY DAY, I
DON’T KNOW WHAT THE PURPOSE OF
IT IS AT SOME POINT.
SARAH CAN GIVE A STATEMENT AND
SAY THAT’S ALL I HAVE TO SAY AND
KEEP GOING.
>> I SAID THIS OVER AND OVER
AGAIN DURING HIGH TIME THERE AND
SINCE THEN, THE BRIEFING USED TO
SERVE A PURPOSE, THAT -- ACTIONS
OR POLICY OR PERSONNEL DECISIONS
THAT OCCURRED.
IN LOOU OF WHEN THE PRESIDENT
CAN -- LEOU.
THEY ASK THE TIME QUESTION OVER
AND OVER AGAIN.
DESPITE THE FACT THEY GOT THE
ANSWER THEY WANT TO GET THEIR
CLIP ON TELEVISION OR TO BE ABLE
TO SHOW IT TO THEIR AUDIENCE.
IT’S NOT ABOUT GETTING
INFORMATION ANY MORE, IT’S NOT
ABOUT INFORMING A PUBLIC.
IT’S ABOUT MAKING "YOU TUBE"
STARS OUT OF ALL OF THE FOLKS
COME IN DAY IN AND DAY OUT.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT IS
IMPORTANT, WHAT YOU’RE GETTING
AT, IT’S NOT JUST WHAT THEY
COVER IT’S WHAT THEY DON’T
COVER.
WE TALK ABOUT THE PRESIDENT BUT
I THINK THAT JOY BEHAR’S ATTACK
ON THE VOICE PRESIDENT’S
CHRISTIANITY AND FAITH IS JUST
DESPICABLE DURING THIS HOLY
SEASON OF LENT.
DEPLORABLE THAT SHE WENT AND DID
THAT.
IT WAS THE VOICE PRESIDENT WHO
HAD TO RESPOND HIMSELF, AND
DEFEND HIMSELF, INSTEAD OF
HAVING ANY OTHER MEMBER -- OR
JOY BEHAR AND SAY THAT WAS OVER
THE LINE.
>> Sean: THAT’S THE POINT.
AND I JUST KNOW THAT IF A
CONSERVATIVE SAYS ONE THING ONE
WORD ONE SENTENCE ONE PHRASE,
THE REACTION IS LIKE, OH, YOU
KNOW, THE OUTRAGE, NO REVISING
AND EXTENDING REMARKS,
APOLOGIZING IF YOU WERE WRONG
AND MISSTATE SOMETHING.
>> YEAH.
AND, LOOK, I SAID SIX YEARS WITH
THE RNC, LITTLE TOMMY, WEST
JEFFERSON MIDDLE SCHOOL WAS
RUNNING FOR TREASURER SAID
SOMETHING OFFENSIVE THE RNC GOT
CALLED ABOUT WHAT OUR COMMENT
WAS.
THE ANSWER WAS THAT’S NOT WHAT
THEY MEANT.
>> Sean: DO YOU SEE THAT THE
MEDIA IS COMPLICIT, AFTER ALL
THAT TIME YOU SPENT AS PRESS
SECRETARY, YOU DON’T HAVE TO
ANSWER IF YOU DON’T WANT.
ARE THEY COMPLICIT?
ARE THEY, DO YOU SEE THEM
TOTALLY IN THE TANK FOR ONE SIDE
AS I DO?
>> I THINK MOST.
I DON’T LIKE TO LOOP EVERYBODY
IN ON THE SAME BROAD BRUSH.
THERE ARE GOOD FOLKS THERE THAT
REALLY TRY TO PURSUE GOOD
JOURNALISM AND THE TRUTH.
BUT I THINK THERE ARE SOME THAT
I’LL NUM RATE IN MY BOOK THAT’S
COMING OUT.
THAT’S WHAT THEY SHOULD BE
PRAISED.
THERE ARE FOLKS YOU MENTIONED
WHO ARE MORE INTERESTED IN
GETTING CLICKS AND BECOMING A
STAR.
BUT WHEN WAS THE LAST TIME JIM
ACOSTA BROKE ANY NEWS?
HIS ENTIRE CAREER IS MADE OUT OF
THE EXCHANGES AND THE YELLING HE
HAS AND THE LEVEL OF OBNOXIOUS
THAT HE REACHES TO AS OPPOSED TO
THE NEWS THAT HE BREAKS AND THE